hey guys today it is the second of
December my name is Jess look doll and
here's what mattered in gaming to them
life is strange developer don't not have
shared more details about their upcoming
vampire themed game of on Pierre rompio
set in britain during 1918 as the city
struggles with the spanish flu you play
a military surgeon called Jonathan a
raid who returns from war and becomes a
vampire don't not have confirmed that
Ronquillo will not be released
episodically as life is strange was and
will be published by focus home
interactive the developer added that
they believe the vampire genre is still
under explored in games and has untapped
potential the game plans to address the
struggling dualities of being both a
doctor and vampire although they're
promising left glitter Margaret
multiplayer betas have been letting us
down a bit lately but uncharted 4 is
hoping to alleviate that by starting
their multiplayer beta sooner than
expected tsarni have announced that the
multiplayer beta for uncharted 4 a
thief's end will begin tomorrow on
December third instead of December
fourth when it was originally slated to
launch PlayStation Europe's official
twitter account revealed that the beta
will be available starting 9 a.m. PT
tomorrow morning and will end on
December 13 the beta client is around
seven gigabytes and to access the beta
you'll need to have purchased to the
Nathan Drake collection as Sony have
announced a no other way to access it
Jill Jacques had said the beta comes
with two maps and one mode but you can
expect more in the full game when that
comes to ps4 in March of next year
finally rocket League has been rated for
Xbox one suggesting that it could arrive
on the platform soon the soccer cars
game was rated for Xbox one by a
Taiwanese videogame rating board the
listing was spotted by komatsu and
twitter user life laura and is the
second clue that rocket leagues
playstation exclusivity is pending the
first was develop a psionic saying that
it may announce the game for additional
platform by the end of the year studio
director dave hodges said we're looking
at all kinds of platforms and there may
be some announcements coming up at some
point hopefully before the end of the
year but I can't
burn that smart money is on the fact
that will hear rocket League and else
for those other platforms pretty damn
soon let me know down in the comments of
your keen / rocket League to come to
xbox one and be sure to head to gamespot
or we've got stories on the xbox one
2016 lineup and how to get the witcher 3
cheap that is everything i have for you
today but through join me same time
tomorrow for a bunch more news